people are asking me about my status
elites tweet um i've been thinking a lot
about status versus wealth recently
and the reason i've been thinking about
status versus wealth is because
i think deep down
you know all of us want to be free
everybody wants to be free nobody wants
to be told what to do or how to live
their life according to anybody else and
one of the
and kind of the easiest path to their
freedom to get rid of a certain set of
troubles you know to get rid of the
money problems is money so even though
uh you know most people will say they're
above it or they don't need it or it's
not part of happiness
i don't think the world would be a worse
place if we made everybody richer and i
don't mean the sense that we double the
money in their bank accounts that's just
a nominal thing but i mean like a real
thing like if everybody had a you know
nicer house and we could make it
environmentally conscious and everybody
had a nicer car and we could make an
electric car
and everybody had you know enough food
on the table and everybody had reliable
high quality internet and bandwidth
whatever they had if they had two ex of
it the world would be a better place i
don't think the world would be a worse
place so i think overall uh making
everybody richer uh and i don't even
talk about socialism let me talk about
redistribution i'm just saying everybody
richer would be a good thing and wealth
is a positive sum game the reason
businesses work the reason silicon
valley works is because we can we can
get together create a product or service
and create more value more wealth than
before we found it so this positive some
game of capitalism i think gets a bad
rap and so i don't think there's
anything wrong with wanting to be
wealthy the problem is
that people uh you know they they signal
against wealth they talk about how money
is the root of all evil or they you know
say oh i'm beyond wealth i don't want
wealth or they attack income inequality
and so on and a lot of this is people
just status signaling they're trying to
gain status in the eyes of the tribe
saying look i'm looking out for the
entire tribe
not just the few people who are getting
ahead
and what i don't like and you know
status signal is needed to some extent
you just can't have the oligarchs around
the world uh you have to have other
hierarchies besides a money-based
hierarchy a money-based hierarchy by the
oligarchy
so
you know you want other ways to order
people other than oligarchy obviously
there are many more things that have
merit but i find that many of the others
are zero-sum games whereas with wealth
we can all be wealthy all of us you know
imagine if the entire world imagine if
everybody in the world was a hardware
engineer or software engineer right
just don't ask me how but we have a
magic demon who can come in and retrain
everybody right he's the education demon
and turns everybody into an engineering
level or phd level uh you know masters
or phd level good engineer in software
hardware whatever you want chemical
engineering pick some hard science but
you know a real engineer i guarantee you
that within five years
the robots would be doing all the work
in the world and we would be living with
massive wealth and abundance and we
would all be better off um so why not
why shouldn't we go for that so recently
i've been thinking a lot about wealth or
status because one of the things that
annoys me about status and status is the
currency that politicians and academics
and journalists move in it's a zero-sum
game where for me to be higher status
than you you have to be lower status
than me or vice versa the the thing i
don't like about the status game is that
one of the ways they seek status is by
attacking wealth
and i think it's great to basically
create wealth for all of us abundance
and one of the things you know one of
the reasons why i get on periscope is
because honestly
i want to
tell people whatever i know about how to
make money in an ethical honest positive
uh you know non-zero-sum kind of way um
so that that is a goal of mine and i've
been working on a related tweet storm
but anyway you know someone saying make
sure only the people who own the robot
see the wealth well i mean at some point
you know something uh becomes so
abundant that everybody has it by
default you know at some point human
society became so advanced that we
decided to have roads and sidewalks and
now everybody benefits from road and
sidewalks whether or not they're part of
the system or not so i would say overall
um wealth creation if done right if done
in a non-monopolistic way um you know
can make everybody rich no jackie
actually says well
it's relative uh that's not true um you
know uh you're trying to make it a
zero-sum game again yes it's relative in
the sense that i can score it against
each other but
you know if i'm uh you know
if i'm a millionaire and my neighbor's a
billionaire
we can both still drive nice cars we can
both still eat well you know it's his
being a billionaire or her being a
billionaire it doesn't take anything
away from me
so you have to get out of that relative
mindset because if you get into that
relative mindset you're always going to
hate people who do better than you
you're always going to be jealous you'll
be envious of them
and and they'll sense that when you try
and do business with them when you try
and do business with somebody and if you
have any bad thoughts about them uh or
any judgments about them they will feel
it you know humans are wired to kind of
feel
what the other person deep down side
feels don't think you're so clever that
you can hide it so to the extent that
you have uh you know distaste or malice
in your heart for someone that you're
trying to do business with
if you resent them uh they're not gonna
do business with you and so literally uh
you know
being anti-wealth will prevent you from
becoming wealthy because the
you will not have the right mindset for
it you won't have the right spirit and
you won't be dealing with people on the
right level
so be optimistic you know be positive
it's important optimists actually do
better in the long run
[Music]
you